Eric starts off this hour in Atlanta hi
Eric how are you how's any better nobody
will believe me how about you just the
same sir how can I help ya well work at
the fire department and I just took a
new job at another fire department and
every ship they like to eat dinner
together
for the past 3 years I've been taking my
dinner from from home leftovers and at
the new job everybody likes to pitch in
and fix one big meal together and I'm
perfectly fine with that I like doing
that but me and my wife are having a
little disagreement on where that money
should come from she thinks it should
come from our grocery money and I think
it should come from my spending money so
she told me to call you and figure it
out okay what if we didn't do either
what if we just made a new line in the
budget that's just that amount we can do
that I like throwing every single penny
I can at paying everything off no but I
mean all you got to do is reduce you
know I you can do whatever you want to
do it doesn't matter as long as you're
doing it on purpose and you're paying
cash for it how big and expenses this
it's only like five or six dollars per
ship and I only work ten times a month
so fifty bucks a month right okay and
how big is your food budget dollars a
month okay and how big is your spending
money a month I get about $75 okay well
maybe you split it between the two
doesn't matter there's no hard and fast
rule I mean one of these things is not
stupid and the other one's smart the
thing that would be stupid is to let
this break your budget or to not do it
on purpose and you at least you got you
guys are in agreement we got to give
this a name you're just arguing about
where which category is sticking and it
doesn't matter
I mean I kind of hate to destroy 300 all
our food budget 50 bucks is a pretty
heavy hit on it and the $75 you know
personal account of 50 bucks is a big
hit on it so that's kind of where I what
went through my head maybe you split it
between the two and both of you survived
and we paid off
I'm right at 25,000 since August so I
just I'd really hate to unplug that yeah
what I'm saying is I might make the food
budget 275 and I might make your budget
50 and then I might have a $50 dinner
budget no as I took it out of those two
you see what I did but do whatever you
want I don't care anywhere in there is
fine if you want to take it out on one
of the other it doesn't matter but one
of you is not right and what is wrong
it's just a matter of it is food in that
sense you know she's right and it is
something that's not a hundred percent
absolutely has to happen for our family
to survive so in that sense it is your
spending money you know so you're both
kind of have good and you know reasons
for putting it in both those categories
the cool thing about the whole
discussion is there you're on the same
page you're working together you are you
know you both are willing to sacrifice
to cause this to happen and that's just
so much further ahead than most people
that I know you're gonna be okay
I know you're gonna be more than okay